our fries chicken disaster markers
determined every piece will be cooked to
perfection today please mark four
portions Table two in three minutes
piece final touch is to grill it to turn
the skin a delicious golden-brown mark
your dishes it's supposed to be crucial
to the skin it looks any good I don't
need to come across is first table table
five please gently happily that mark no
no what's that fragrance again jasmine
very nice mark has gone the extra mile
and his food looks wonderful exactly
about it from the mango tree you can see
my face this is wow that's all for me
the finishing line is within sight when
the unthinkable happens
let me show it to the chef okay take it
away for you
double six big service I needed to not
have any this chef they say their
chicken is undercooked where's the
underclass [ __ ] there's their last
line come off the bone there you see it
clear as day
[ __ ] me
[ __ ] I'm so pissed off
peen chicken comes back again and to us
every time not disturb it is right now
not good enough for more mark please how
long just two returns I can tell the
time will remain minute three minutes of
Table one please tell Rob
don't worry rather leg yeah [ __ ] the leg
pretty pissed off they eat my own words
I'm not happy
[ __ ] you check the lips see them on the
leaf as well yeah yeah go don't want
these yeah
even I could never have guessed servers
would end like this for mango tree it's
been a challenging night for everyone
but it's time to find out what my
diner's thought on both dishes starting
with mango tree
let's talk chicken while ours wasn't
cooked no well that was a ridiculous
mistake my apologies it just wasn't even
leaving the bone was it it was probably
still puffing fortunately not all my
diners at the same experience is great
when it came yes and that hurts
go right through it the mango tree
because I love the chicken on the bone
it kept it really moist very very tasty
and the broth where they just lovely I
had to go for 19 because I like this so
much so much it's beautifully marinated
subtle and then you've got the sauces
complementing now I face a very
difficult choice which one of these two
restaurants should go through to the
semi-finals
for Gordon Ramsay to say you the best
that is meant a lot I will never forget
it neither restaurant has been without
fault but even good restaurants have
their bad days
I'm obviously hoping at the other 19
dishes make a bigger impact and
impression than the one but can I
forgive mark for under cooking chicken
again